ده الامور خرجت عن السيطره هناك فوضى
عالمه الان في شوارع العاصمه باريسنا
بالقرب على بعد امتار من ساحه الجمهوريه
تعزيزات امنيه من كل صوب الان تاتي هنا
على يمينه كما ترون الشرطه تحاول تفريق
المتظاهرين المتظاهرون يردون عليها برشقها
بالحجاره والمقذوفات
ايضا يقومون بعمليات احراق كما ترون هنا
قاموا بقلب سيارات وباحرقها
التظاهره بالدرجه الاولى جاءت بدعوه من
امام المركز الثقافي الكردي احمد كايا
الذي تعرض
للهجوم وكانت تابينا للضحايا وتكريما لهم
وايضا اا رفضا لي الروايه الفرنسيه التي
في مازال تقول ان القاتل الذي نفذ هذه
العمليه قام
بتنفيذها من تلقاء نفسه لذا هم يرفضون هذه
الروايه الفرنسيه ويقولون ان تركيا لها
ارتباطات بهذه العمليه
ويستدلون على ذلك من طبيعه المكان الذي
استهدف بانه استهدف ايضا في عام 2013
اغتيلات فيه ثلاث ناشطات كرديات همم
ويقولون ان هذه العمليه مشابهه لما حدث
عام 2013 والشرطه الفرنسيه لم تكن همم
تحمي هذا المركز يحملون الشرطه الفرنسيه
سياسيه وفنيه كثيره جدا للاكراد وكل
الاشخاص الثلاثه الذين قتلوا وهم نجاء همم
يعرفهم او ي- ياتون الى المركز باستمرار
احدى هؤلاء كانت سيده هي كانت مقاتله
سابقه ضد تنظيم داعش في شمال سوريا نقلت
الى فرنسا للعلاج بعد اصابتها هناك خلال
المعارك انتهى يوم عصيب في العاصمه
الفرنسيه وبدات الان تتضح حجم الخسائر قوى
الاطفاء الان تحاول اطفاء بعض الحرائق
التي ما زالت مشتعله في عدد من الشوارع
ساحه الجمهوريه خلت تماما الان من
المتظاهرين الذين تفرقوا في عدد من
الشوارع الفرعيه لكن قوات الامن والشرطه
الفرنسيه ما زالت منتشره في الشوارع تحسبا
لاحتمال تجدد الاشتباكات مع المحتجين هذه
دهوك العربيه باريس